something sims and i talked about
earlier today the best news out of the
first three weeks is the fact that 48
out of 48 games were played and that the
pandemic wasn't an issue
maybe that counts as a jinx because not
long after we wrapped pft live earlier
this morning the news came out that the
titans and vikings had closed their
facilities until further notice because
of an outbreak
within the titans organization three
players five members of the non-playing
staff testing positive contact tracing
further testing the titans shut down
until saturday for crying out loud at
least until saturday good luck
practicing
and preparing for a football game when
you can't get into the building to have
football practice
but shireen this was a stunner on one
hand because i think we got to the point
where we thought hey three weeks we're
fine this is good they've mastered this
they've cracked the code they've reached
a level of no infiltration and then the
first moment we exhale a little bit here
it is
yeah and roger goodell's statement today
he said this is not a surprise and i i
think probably the bigger surprise is
that it lasted this long that they made
it this long playing all these games
without any kind of interruption and we
don't know if this is going to be an
interruption yet or not there's a lot of
things they can do here and maybe maybe
not the titans and steelers get to play
but i think the biggest concern probably
mike is it's three different position
groups it's a defensive tackle long
snapper and a tight end so now you've
got three different rooms to worry about
as opposed to just hey it's all in the
quarterback's room or the running backs
room or whatever you've got various
rooms here you've got to worry about
with those players so i do think this is
a concern and a concern whether the
steelers will be traveling to the titans
to play this week
and they've got the point of care
testing where they can quickly determine
about sending the test sample off to a
laboratory whether or not it's positive
they still will send samples off to a
laboratory by tomorrow we should have a
pretty good idea of where things stand
because presumably they hustled to get
testing done today after getting a bunch
of positives back presumably today from
yesterday they have daily testing but
the thing is the players still have days
off i assume they don't come in to get
tested on the days that they are off so
that monday tuesday window can be a
little incomplete as to when guys are
being tested but the reality is it's
possible that there were players who
were shedding virus as the technical
term goes when the titans were playing
the vikings on sunday so far the vikings
no positives which is good
and we just wait now everything is on
hold while time passes and assurances
are obtained that there isn't a
full-blown outbreak but as you mentioned
with a guy who is positive with three
different position groups you have to be
concerned about that and if a defensive
tackle's positive you got to worry about
the offensive lineman from the vikings
that he was pressing up against from
time to time during that three-hour
window on
sunday and you know mike the thing that
instantly came to my mind was when we
talked about roger goodell saying hey
there's no competitive advantage for
teams that have fans in the stands and
some do some don't there's no
competitive advantage and now we may get
a situation where the steelers are going
to be allowed to practice all week long
same with the texans and then they go
out and play the game and the titans
have what maybe one day of practice and
they can't practice offsite it's not
like they can go somewhere else and and
ryan tannehill can throw to his
receivers that's not allowed either
they're not allowed to do that so
they're just doing virtual meetings all
this week and i just
playing the steelers and as complicated
as their defense is this is a huge
companion competitive disadvantage for
the titans if they have to go into that
game with a saturday practice and play
on sunday
yeah i think what roger goodell should
have said when the question came up
about the potential competitive
advantage of having fans present and not
having fans present this is nothing
compared to the competitive advantages
and disadvantages that may be visited
upon teams if we get ourselves into an
outbreak georgia tall the nflpa
spokesman was on earlier with brother
from another here's some of what atala
had to say about the level of anxiety
that this news is creating
so are you confident george that that
again no no this virus is unpredictable
but just based on what you know as you
sit here now
um do you feel pretty good that this can
be contained or or is this perhaps
something bigger in the beginning of it
what's your gut tell you right now i
hope it's not another question but just
i'm nervous yeah okay yeah i'm nervous i
really am i'm nervous like the like the
rest of us i mean
look the reality is
you can trust the virus you can't trust
humans
and you we know now what the how the
virus spreads we know
more about infection we know about
asymptomatic spread
um
we know that these things actually
protect us
uh from from the spread
and and you're seeing even community
spread like let's take the nfl out of it
new york city is starting to have
community spread over three percent
again and i think that's a result of
people having fatigue but
this is going to be a grind for
um
everybody until we have some sort of
better solution or vaccine
again that's georgia tala nflpa
spokesman i love george it's a serious
situation but i cannot let that clip go
without saying matt patricia would have
told george to sit up straight in that
chair when he's talking
other than that i have no problem with
what he said uh look here's the reality
there is fatigue there is
complacency and one of the things the
nfl was concerned about is complacency
setting in when teams begin to fade from
contention
shireen later in the year and as the
numbers begin to spike as the flu season
begins people are indoors more
assuming the nfl can get through this
and that's a big assumption at this
point if nothing else this is a reminder
a very valuable reminder that the virus
does set the agenda as george said you
can trust the virus you can't trust
people and maybe
a scare like this will help avert a
bigger problem later in the year that
could unfold as we get teams who
they don't have a chance their players
don't care the one thing the players
need to realize even if their teams are
mathematically eliminated or as a
practical matter have a fork stuck in
them and are done
if games are missed you don't get paid
so your livelihood your financial
security hinges on being able to play
the games that to you otherwise don't
mean anything and also you want to play
the games you create film you may end up
with a different team next year you want
to compare favorably to the other people
and it's still competition but to the
extent that there is that concern that
guys could get a little bit lacks later
in the year especially from teams that
aren't successful this is that warning
shot do not let up do not relent and i
hope at the end of the day shireen they
find out exactly what happened how did
that virus get into the building and
what can they do to prevent it in the
future
yeah you know shane bowen the defensive
play caller and outside linebackers
coach for the titans the first word came
out yesterday that he didn't make the
trip with the team
to the vikings that he had coveted he
went on the covet or went on the covet
list we assumed now that he had covet so
did he spread it to the rest of the team
you know how did this go and you just
don't know and they may never know but
that's was our first word that something
was amiss with this team and and now
here we are uh with the players who've
tested positive and things have shut
down but here's another thing mike i
think this serves as a warning perhaps
to
the fan situation in the nfl the titans
were supposed to have 7 000 fans this
week at their game then 8 500 on october
11th and then 10 000 on october 18th are
we still going to do that we don't know
the answer to that quite yet but i i do
think this serves as a warning that
yes we all have the fatigue and i'm not
wiping down everything like i used to
and doing all those things and i shook
the doctor's hand today and did some of
those things that we wouldn't have done
maybe a month two months ago
but we've all got to be careful and in
the nfl they especially need to be
careful so as you said they keep playing
and keep getting paid and all that stuff
we want to see games
a compelling data point in this will be
whether or not any of the vikings
players end up with it assuming that
there was a situation where titan's
players were positive with the virus on
sunday because one of the things the nfl
has believed throughout this process the
open-air setting even if you're in a
dome with the high roof with the
ventilation it's enough to
prevent or minimize spread because you
don't have the droplets that are just
hanging around like they are in an
indoor setting where there's poor
ventilation so if no vikings end up with
this that's actually a good thing and it
will show that the spread was confined
to
airplanes hotels you know whatever about
buses whatever
spaces that the titans players may have
been in so what happens this weekend
with the steelers going to tennessee the
vikings going to houston everything is
on hold right now
there's a report that
the nfl intends to go forward on sunday
with steelers titans as scheduled which
shireen as you mentioned creates a
competitive disadvantage for the titans
because they don't get to practice and
the steelers do
another possibility is to move the game
to monday which could maybe give the
titans a chance to practice on saturday
there isn't much you can do though on
saturday now the packers tend to push
their week up to the point where they
have a walk through the day before
the game so if you're the titans you
could have a semi-real practice on on
saturday i guess i'll walk through on
sunday and play monday night but that's
going to be a challenge for the titans
because it's going to be very dissimilar
to what the steelers are doing the other
possibility and the first thing i did i
started looking at schedules when is the
titans buy when does the steelers buy
well the titans buy is week seven the
steelers buy is week eight so you can't
just bump it to the mutual bye week but
the steelers and the ravens play week
seven the steelers and the ravens have a
week eight buy it would be easy to
reconfigure things so that the steelers
and titans have their by week four the
steelers and titans play week seven the
steelers and ravens play week eight so
the ravens move their by up a week the
only problem is for the steelers and
again
crap happens you're going to have
competitive disadvantages you're going
to have inconveniences the steelers may
very well end up not having a bye week
other than missing a game because you
spend all week practicing for a game
that doesn't happen
and then
you spend your bye week
practicing for a game that does happen
when you otherwise would have been off
so look that happened a couple of years
ago when it was i think buccaneers
dolphins remember there was a hurricane
game that had the plug pulled on it and
the teams played consistently 16 weeks
after that they never had a bye week
either that happens and that may be what
happens here
yeah a lot of things could could happen
with this for sure mike here's a
question though if you're the
commissioner would you consider
shutting down the steelers facility and
just saying hey we're going to go ahead
and play the game both facilities reopen
on saturday this is the way it is
competitive uh no competitive advantage
for anyone you're just going to have to
do virtual meetings come back saturday
practice and play the game sunday could
you see that happening that's a great
idea and yes i would i think that's the
best way to create an apples-to-apple
situation hey look the titans are
strapped by this reality and the
steelers have to be
subjected to an equal situation but
here's my response to it the steelers
haven't allowed an outbreak to happen in
their facility the titans have this is
part of the price you pay for not you
know because this is the ultimate pass
fail
either you do keep the virus out or you
don't
and if however it happened and we may
never know
however it happened wherever it happened
whenever it happened the titans get an f
and the steelers get a p
so the steelers get to practice
and the titans don't and that's the
price you pay for not ensuring that you
keep the virus out of your facility i
mean that's why i'm a firm believer
teams shouldn't get a dispensation if
they don't have enough guys ready to go
if they are wiped out at a position
group well you should you should number
one kept the virus out number two plan
your roster accordingly to account for
the possibility that you're going to not
have all of your players they don't do
that for injuries they shouldn't do that
for this that'll be another interesting
situation if
they
decide that there is a group of titans
players who will be on the covet 19
reserve list the rest of them are good
to go
will they say to the titans you still
don't have to play this week because we
want you to be able to play when you
have all of your guys i don't think that
should be the case because at some point
there's responsibility on the titans for
allowing this virus into their building
i would not want to be in charge of
anything right now because these are
hard decisions to make and whatever
decision you make it's going to be
criticized by somebody and nobody not
everybody is going to be happy with
whatever decision
you you do make so the commissioner's in
this position he's
paid gazillions as we know to make these
decisions and he's got a hard decision
to make but he's going to have to make
this and maybe he does go with what you
said you know titans allowed it to enter
their facility whether
fault of their own or not it got there
the steelers have not maybe it is a
competitive advantage for the steelers
this week i would love to see this game
i was looking forward to this game uh
with both teams getting to practice all
week but i do think if the steelers get
to practice the titans don't i i can't
see the titans winning this game even if
they are have home field advantage this
was going to be a dose of cold water for
the titans anyway the three teams they
barely beat are one in eight a combined
six and oh
pair of opponents were coming in with
the steelers and the bills so yeah i i
don't think it was gonna go well for the
titans anyway potentially now it becomes
even harder and it'll be interesting to
see what that does to the betting lines
is it off the board when's it on the
board will they take action on it we've
never had a situation like this where
one team can't prepare and the other
team can as a practical matter and
sharing you mentioned the possibility of
the tom brady type of gathering at a
local high school they're not going to
let the guys do it now does that stop
them from doing it on their own if they
do it discreetly enough i guess it
doesn't if they do it outside of the
probing eyes of big brother and big
brother as we know is all of us carrying
around the cell phone devices that can
spot whatever it is may be happening but
ideally they'd be prevented from doing
that the idea at this point contain the
spread contact trace
testing
and ensure that whoever has it is
isolated the people who don't have it
stay away and we get to a point where
they can play football this weekend and
just get the games in and again there
will be competitive disadvantages far
greater than not having fans at the
games as the season unfolds if outbreaks
happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports